[Music]
in bully bloc news submitted by El
Capitan Instagram will Oh Instagram will
be using a I intervention in hopes to
cut down on bullying how to do that I
think you'll probably like snag keywords
and comments but it can't read into
sarcasm dude I can barely read in
sarcasm on text [ __ ] crazy on text
Twitter not Instagram I wonder if there
is a common bullying algorithm out there
like oh if they say this this happens in
a lot of bullying incidents or whatever
what they're saying is that they have
been using and testing this new AI
feature that whenever someone posted a
comment that's similar to something that
has been previously reported that's when
it'll be flagged oh it looks like you
sure you want to send them yeah so it
sounds like you are so ugly and stupid
and then it says are you sure you want
to post this learn more and then we
click on learn more it says keeping
Instagram in supportive plates we're
asking people to rethink comments that
seem similar to others that have been
reported if we made a mistake let us
know so they're making you like think
twice before doing yeah but that's gonna
just become like another button to
people to get through if you're really
an [ __ ] mr. Graham is not a
supportive place I was going through the
comments and then someone wrote know
what they should be doing is like are
you sure you want to send this and then
it says like oh this is where your
location is I'm like that's the [ __ ]
thing they should be doing yes yes a lot
of people that actually do talk [ __ ]
don't show their face it's not their
account they have another four they
don't give a [ __ ] about that like and
why do they need us on Instagram it just
it's like Mark Zuckerberg feels bad for
selling all of our addresses to Russia
and this is like you being like oh I'm
doing something about the bullying and
the hate I think there's a lot of
studies that are showing a lot of teens
have a huge spike in depression as an
Instagram and especially in female teens
there's higher rates of suicide
yeah because everyone's comparing
themselves to [ __ ] do jihad do you
know Jews are through that's why it's
not supported place [ __ ] blow me and
so if Instagram is a comparative reality
place yeah
this no no man I got a lot to say and I
don't think anyone should ever be [ __ ]
revealed for posting something no
[ __ ] way you don't think as someone's
like I'm gonna come blow up your school
that's a different thing that's it
that's a threat I'm talking about like
posting like hey [ __ ] you you're ugly or
something I don't think it's like hey
we're gonna let everyone know you live
in Albuquerque oh yeah Daxing is weird
but I also I'm kind of like 50/50 on the
whole anonymous thing and showing your
profile in full name like I'm kind of
one of it is like yes we need it on the
internet and the choice to to kind of be
something that were not or just for
other reasons right because we it's like
a different playground part of having
privacy right if you want to be private
and have just like a character account
or whatever you can still do that
because that is a part of internet
culture but the other part of me is like
you [ __ ] that talk [ __ ] show your
[ __ ] face cuz you don't think they
would be more inclined to leave a
comment if it's their real man they're
just a [ __ ] avatar in like [ __ ] 6
9 6 9
yes they can get away with anything
right so it's a form of abuse and it's
but then there's other people that don't
do that
but they shouldn't be Doc's or they
shouldn't have everything online feel
like you should not maybe show their
location but like their real name cuz
it's like if you're a [ __ ] [ __ ]
show you're an [ __ ] I think their
face that's hard too because like I
think it's just people express your
negativity or like a bad day cuz even
like on the freeway
someone can just like randomly flip you
off and just drive off real fast so that
to me is kind of the same thing as
people just leaving a comment so maybe
like I feel like what did me like I want
people just be them but maybe there
could be like a surgeon general's
warning like hey people could or cannot
be these people it could be fake but
please like always take things with a
grain of salt don't make it too serious
yeah but like that's environmental
versus like what instagram has become
it's the place where people are trying
to show their best selves and so
someone's constantly [ __ ] on like
your best self versus if you are like
you being a slow driver in the left hand
lane that maybe you deserve to be just
be like what the platform is is the same
thing what happened with YouTube where
it was like we thought YouTube was gonna
be this place to share yeah artistic
creativity yeah yeah and it just became
this like jerk off zone of [ __ ] hate
and there's no regular
for me it's more about people are gonna
do what they want to do and if they want
to be it like their highlight reel they
can but the the teens or whoever that
are suffering from it I think maybe
there's a way we can help them change
their perspective on how they receive
this comparative yeah there's no [ __ ]
support for people who get harassed
online I know I've gotten death threats
before like email sent to my personal
email someone once found out where I
used to live based on like an old
Instagram story where you saw my
apartment complex in the background yeah
and they found out I had a guy show up
to my house in the middle I was I had
zeroes up where I had no resources I
didn't know who to call to like be like
this is [ __ ] alarming you don't have
there's no support system so I think
you're right like step want to start
with the mental health aspect of it of
like what are these people do who are
the victims of it instead of that's true
maybe not a [ __ ] perpetrator
it's like someone being your you know
big brother or big sister being us like
helping you become street smart on the
streets we need someone that is like
guiding the new generation to get go
through the internet like how do you
have internet smart so you don't get
[ __ ] you know finished and you don't
get scammed and you'll get cat like
whatever it's like all these things
people just get they don't learn unless
it happens to them because I'm on the
AOL generation about be part of like
health class you know in high school
where they teach you by your own body
they could have like this what to look
out for where it's like being on online
teach my grandma how to avoid [ __ ]
cruise scams [ __ ] free shows every
other time yeah exactly
so that's one of the features and then
another feature that they're talking
about is called restrict and so this is
what it looks like so if you have
someone that's bullying you you can
restrict that person and then it says
are you having a problem with so-and-so
protect yourself from unwanted
interactions without them knowing only
you and them will be able to see their
own new comment
they won't see when you're online or
when you've read their messages as well
seat that's tight they're screaming into
the void like they think that there are
comments being seen by others cuz they
can beat themselves and you had the
option to approve their comment for the
public to see if you've restricted this
person but so a lot of people what
Instagram was saying is that we just own
that's the thing they've shown that will
start now been bullied they're too
afraid to to block them or to do
anything else because they know if they
notice person in real life and they'll
bail retail you shouldn't yeah that's
not really smart like screaming into the
voice that's great
cuz then if you're having a problem or
job 6969 yeah just [ __ ] put them in
the void and they think that their faith
in their comment well you can't see what
their comment is either you can't see
you can
oh but that's what sucks no you don't
want to see that comment exactly that's
why you block oh but no one else can see
no one else it's like if someone far in
your face right you still smell that
that's true but I think it's better than
the whole school laughing at you that's
someone funny in fact the problem of
like [ __ ] Charles online man I think
that comes from inside the house yes for
sure parents but I think Bart's right
about there's always gonna be bad people
there's always gonna bark hello it's
your name so like Simpson yeah so how do
we deal with that because it's almost
like like well we can't deny the fact
that there's always gonna be criminals
and bad people right so Lane
same with online there's always gonna be
trolls negative people people that just
don't like you for you just existing
yeah for your face whatever I get more
like I think you have a very punchable
face and I'm like I agree with you what
do we do about this but like do you
think that the person who's doing the
trolling that's gonna get blocked is
thinking about the effect it's having on
the person like I feel so celebrity they
just feel like they'll never see this I
can say whatever the [ __ ] I want but if
it's someone who's like in your gray at
your school are they really thinking
about how that might affect that person
do they [ __ ] care beach in it I mean
it's like tissa it's like it's an
educational problem I think yeah and
there's also different forms of bullying
like one might be like things getting
out of hand because you're roasting so
hard and you're having so much fun
and then one is like you intentionally
want to destroy this person because
you're jealous of them or whatever
you're going through your own [ __ ] you
the COS measures company so that's a
good point cuz like I don't know how you
are with your girls but like when I see
my girl and she looks good I'm like yes
you [ __ ] thought I love it and I
might be screened I was like me calling
someone a [ __ ] thought or how many
girls call each other [ __ ] and [ __ ] for
funds all the time you [ __ ] floor
right really oh that's tails is all this
time oh that's an old one and like I
roast these guys here owes me and like I
would hate to lose that yeah you become
closer when you're bored yeah they
should have like another feature where
you can like whitelist people you know
from the thing well are you sure you
want to post it it's like let them talk
as much make some money if you're white
was did you keep impulse porn on my
profile that's like good did I get it's
all in jest bro we're cool I just feel
bad for all these teens that are going
through like crazy depression anxiety
yeah they don't know how to like yeah
their realism and like what they've
experienced in the world is way
different than we like we're stronger in
the minors are always bent they're more
should have been like made fun about the
playground if it's still like this
emerging person there's just constant
negativity of my [ __ ] how do you help
them like I put myself and like and I
think when I'm like 10 years or 15 years
old their Tiger goes oh can I open it
Instagram I'm like oh I don't really
want you to because it's gonna [ __ ] your
brain up but I also don't want to
control you okay that's what you were
just saying it's like it's it happens in
education it's like your parents can
help guide you through this yeah we
learned how to do it cuz we grew up with
it yeah see how to teach like our
parents didn't know how to teach us and
people that are teams right now their
parents may not know cuz they didn't
have it or they're not as yeah like I
think remember how before I was that I
was talking about how he never really
kind of asked to have a phone I have an
11 year and so now he done he has been
asking me like mom I can't
and I'm like getting real cuz we've had
these conversations about how I don't
want him to get like mentally [ __ ]
over with everything that's online once
you give them that access see ah here
comes the porn at an earlier age here
comes the sexual ization I'm jacking off
so much happening that's showing like
I'm like we'll talk about it baby
because remember when you were like a
billion women the way you got to see
porn was like a friend's house who had
like HBO unlocked or like you had to
sneak on to like sex calm it's like now
you have to private its money man it
should be and it's crazy because our
generation was our parents were like oh
my god what we gonna do we didn't have
porn period and now it's like in the
privacy of your own this and you sleep
with it it's right under your head and
it's like but then you also don't wanna
be that helicopter parent that's like I
put locks on my kids I know their
passcode give me your phone and like
when you do that you're revealing so
much about yours like everything about
yourself
versus just what parents need to know
what what's like a healthy level of them
no I mean I will assume as soon as my
kid gets a phone they're probably
watching porn with it [ __ ] yeah holy
[ __ ] I mean like you said you can watch
porn like this you're like I'm watching
porn nobody can see me watching porn
right yeah
like that's [ __ ] weird desensitized
to it yeah that's what happens when you
are addicted yeah that's a very good
point
[Music]
[Music]